the difference between somebody who's  loyal to their wife and somebody who is  not is not the fact that they might have  their eye get caught because that  happens they're human you're going to  have emotions right the difference  between somebody who's loyal not is  whether they cheat it's the same thing  with patience honesty it's not do you  want to lie it's do you choose not to  despite wanting to lie it's just like  courage it's not the absence of fear but  taking action despite it and so I think  a lot of those character traits a lot of  people it feels like these amorphous  things that we want to have and take off  the shelf and put inside of ourselves we  think that we need to feel a certain way  in order to be a patient person or be a  kind person or whatever when at least in  my experience it's been you don't feel  that way and you take the action that a  patient or kind or courageous or loyal  or honest person would take despite the  feeling